- Hey guys.
At ComplexCon a couple weeks ago,
my homie ASAP Ferg and I were
going to do an Ask Gary V.
He got caught up on some business.
So what you're about to watch
is me improving a keynote
and a Q and A session
when I was going in the
mindset of doing an Ask Gary V.
Hope you enjoy it.
A lot of culture talk.
A lot of attention talk.
Some really solid Q and A at the end.
Have a great holiday season.
Hope you're enjoying your
Thanksgiving weekend.
Check it, check it out.
(funky upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
How are you guys?
- [Man in Audience] Great.
- Good.
So, obviously I had to flip my schedule,
and the talk that I was
gonna give from five to six,
is what I'm gonna do now,
and me and Ferg are gonna do
Ask Gary V later on today.
Whenever the fuck he wakes up.
So listen, I wanna take full advantage
of having this much time,
and this intimate of an audience,
so my plan is to kind of maybe
spit a couple of thoughts
that I think could bring some value.
I'm also gonna be empathetic
to know the fact that
most of you have some context on me,
so I don't wanna repeat shit
that I think you guys already know
in this stage of us sharing thoughts
all the time and what have you.
So, I'll talk for about five minutes
and then honestly, I'd
love to go into Q and A.
'Cause I think this is
the best opportunity
for me to answer the
questions so many of you have,
that I can't answer sometimes in a DM
or email or things of that nature, so.
I think the thing that I
would like to talk about here
at ComplexCon is that I've
been here for about an hour,
I wasn't here yesterday, and
there's three or four things
racing through my head on first taste.
Number one, holy shit,
this is exactly like
the baseball card shows that
I grew up in back in the day.
Just watching all those
kids in line for sneakers
and the other swag, trying to
get the limited edition stuff,
flip it, make that dollar, I just,
I mean there might not be
a more interesting show
for me to come to, given that it's really
so close to my true essence.
It's just 25 years later,
so that really stands out
and the entrepreneurial
vibe in that community
to me is really intriguing.
And just watching, obviously,
the main difference is
this shit is a hell of a lot cooler
than baseball cards were.
So watching it kind of
crash into cool culture
and collecting entrepreneurial spirit,
hustler mentality, it's just
super interesting for me.
Never, ever thought in a million years
that 20 year olds that
had this kind of swag
would think I was cool.
Never really wrapped my
head around entrepreneurship
being put on a cultural
pedestal the way it is now.
But I've gotta be very honest,
it makes me super happy.
It makes me super happy that working hard
and trying to achieve something
for you and your family
is something that people now think is cool
in the same way of being
an athlete or a rapper
or an artist of some sort so,
to me this is an incredible time.
The internet has created
so much opportunity.
The fact that so many
people rolling down there,
coming from such humble beginnings,
and they've got a couple of
pins with their business card
on it, or a t-shirt that
they pressed last week.
Just seeing that kind of
grind is super-inspiring
to be very honest with you.
I think the thing that I trade on,
and the thing that makes me so confident
about how this all plays out for me is
I am far more attracted to
the idea of let's go right now
to a printing press and make some shit
and set up a booth in the corner
and nobody knows who the fuck we are
and try to sell something for 10 bucks,
than I am with the thought of like,
I didn't even go out last night, right.
Like 700 DMs of like, yo,
this club and this table
and this spot and these people.
And it's just so interesting
to me, like what draws me in.
And I know that all the
stuff that I got hit up about
last night, is what
draws a lot of people in,
especially the young men in the audience.
I get it, but my hope is that
they get tricked along the way
and fall in love with the process,
not the treasures that come along with it.
That they fall in love with
that intoxicating feeling
to wake up and feel
purposeful about something.
That some shit that went
through their head one day,
that motivated them, they
paste it on a t-shirt
and it got going and it took off.
And so, I think it's an incredible time.
I think the undercurrent
of negativity in society
is feeding it even more.
I think it's the oxygen.
I like the idea of people finally
wrapping their head around
that nobody's gonna do it
for them, not their parents,
not their teachers, not
the government, nobody.
This morning I posted,
nobody owes you shit
on Instagram and just kinda
watched everybody react to it.
It excited me because it's
something I've been saying
on social media for 10 years.
And for the first time, the comments,
'cause you know, for all
the young kids in here
I would give you a huge piece of advice.
Spend a hell of a lot
less time worrying about
how many likes and how many views you get
and start spending a
hell of a lot more time
reading every fuckin'
word somebody replies
to a piece of content you put out.
And more importantly then, take the time
to maybe engage with it,
shit will go in the right direction.
Anyway, after 10 years on Twitter, fuck,
let me go way back, on Myspace and Twitter
and YouTube and Facebook,
and on and on and on,
I would honestly tell you this morning,
the way the community responded
to nobody owes you shit
is probably the most excited
I've ever been because
over the last 10 years
everybody's jumping in
and just coming up with bullshit excuses,
but yeah, but yeah, but
this guy owes me 30 bucks or
you know, just funny, different shit.
This was the most collective
like, I agree, fuck it.
And that has been my calling card,
the reason I get to sit
here, the reason I get to
go downstairs and have this
collaboration with K-Swiss,
or the reason I'm gonna
achieve all my goals in life,
most importantly impacting people
in a way that builds my legacy.
The good I'm trying to
give you is selfish.
Everybody's giving me love
downstairs, I'm selfish,
I need that love.
I feed off the admiration in your eyes.
That isn't what I'm trying to achieve.
All the treasures and all the things
that come along with this,
I got that a long time ago.
I thought I made it
when I made a hundred K.
Hundred K a year was
my barometer at 15, 16,
I was like, when I get a hundred K.
And I wanted to buy the
Jets, but for some reason
a hundred K was like
(clicking tongue) right?
And so, we sit in an incredible time.
We sit in an incredible time,
and if you're sitting here
with me right now at this
kind of event with me,
with this vibe well then you're
99% ahead of everybody else.
I mean it.
If I could just people to
understand the perspective.
The fact that you understand this culture,
the fact that you have that undertone
of entrepreneurship and hunger and drive,
you're legitimately ahead of 99%.
The fact that this is Sunday
morning, and it's early,
and I know we got an hour back last night,
but it's still fuckin' early.
In a world where a lot of people
are just laying in bed right now, a lot.
In a world where three years
ago, you were laying in bed,
to me that's exciting.
And so, this audience and this
convention center inspires me.
And I'm just flattered I can inspire back.
And so, let's talk about another thing
and then we'll open it up for Q and A.
You guys hear this from me
but I'm goin' keep pounding it
because I never wanna ever
let you waiver from it.
It's just about attention, right.
Attention is the game.
Whatever you're trying to achieve,
if you're trying to raise
money for a non-profit,
if you're just trying to
help your mom out at home
with another hundred bucks each month,
or if you're trying to
go for it all, right.
Yachts and planes, materialistically,
or all-time legacy, it's
all gonna be the same game.
Can you understand where
people are paying attention?
That is under-priced.
I understand that, you guys
understand that intuitively,
that's why you're sitting here.
The under-priced attention in our society
is on YouTube, it's on Snapchat,
and right now more than ever
it's on Instagram, right.
And so once you understand that,
and again, you take it for granted.
What you don't understand,
as I look at these young,
pretty faces, is it comes
natural to you to understand
where everybody's trading
and spending time,
but the world isn't acting on that.
My friends, if the biggest
companies in the world understood
what was actually
happening, Nike and Adidas,
those fuckers downstairs,
they'd be spending 70% of their money
on Instagram and Snapchat and YouTube.
And it's not even close.
They'd be dropping product on everybody,
just for the free exposure
of your 7,000 fans
'cause it'd be worth it.
So please do not get it
twisted, do not get confused.
You're ahead of the game
theoretically, strategically.
Now what you gotta figure
out is two core things
that everybody fucks up.
First of all, the shit you
put out on those places
needs to be for people, not for yourself.
The shit that you put
out on these platforms,
everybody's self-promoting,
everybody's trying to get more followers,
everybody's trying to sell something.
The reason I wrote Jab,
Jab, Jab, Right Hook
was trying to make a very
clear picture for you,
like give, give, give, and then ask.
If you pay close attention
to who's winning,
that doesn't have some
disproportionate advantage like
they're already ridiculously famous
and/or they're so fucking
attractive you can't stop looking.
As long as they don't
have those two things,
if you look at everybody
else who's winning,
they're giving in their content,
they're giving in their content.
And, they understand.
Let me give you somethin' small
because I know you guys pay attention.
Why did I put that red bar
at the bottom of my videos?
'Cause I'm testin' shit.
I'm tryin' to figure out
how to bring value, like,
I learned, I don't know
nerdy you guys get,
but like Medium, how
many people know Medium,
the blog post platform?
Cool, you know what they did
that fuckin' like blew my mind?
They told you how long
the article was to read.
This happened like three,
four years ago, right?
You've started seeing it in other places.
I do it on my blog because of it.
It says, three minute
read, two minute read,
four minute read, it was crazy.
It seems so simple but it was so valuable
because time is the most valuable thing.
And so I'm always tryin' new things.
If I can recommend anything for you,
one thing that I've noticed is that
everybody gets into the same
patterns with their content.
Like if you're a good photographer,
you're just takin' fly ass photos,
and it might be the skyline, or the beach,
or a piece of fuckin' fruit,
but it's the same fly ass photo, right.
If you look at my account right now,
I'm mixing it up, it's my normal shit,
like the motivational shit
that I get excited about.
It's the video clips
But I'm tryin' to integrate
more pictures too now like,
you've gotta break up your
cadence 'cause you never know.
And then more importantly
within it, you need to try shit.
And so, the red bar is just tryin' shit
because I knew that you'd
know how long the video was.
Like meme videos, the white
borders and the white,
like I love it when I say
this and people are like,
oh shit, that's true,
somebody did that first.
There was some person
that's like, fuck it,
this is how I'm gonna
put out the video, right?
Or the picture, like there is
a human that did that first.
I implore you to strive to
be more creative with your
content, and be the first to
do it this way or that way.
'Cause if god forbid, a.k.a. please god,
if it pops, you can trade
just on that legacy.
Like, if I was walking
right now, it's like yo-yo,
I'm the dude that came up with the,
yo I'm the girl that
came up with the meme.
I'd be like, oh shit,
let's hang, how'd you do,
like, it's unbelievable
and to me it all comes down
to the context of all this, which is,
this is just all culture.
And what's amazing
about culture right now,
is it can come from any angle.
I'm old, at 42, growing up
with hip hop the way I did,
you had to be hard, like if you go read,
some of you are youngsters,
you haven't read the history.
A lot of rappers made shit
up, like that they came from
a different place than
they actually came from.
Because if you weren't like
hood, and if you weren't
fuckin' hard, you had no shot.
Now, the fact that all of you could just
legitimately be who you wanna be,
that's what everything fuckin' completely
collided into each other.
All the different cultures
that I grew up with,
and definitely the people
before me, that were separate,
all that shit is fuckin' just
colliding into each other.
In fashion, in the music, in
the food, in the way we roll.
And that's such a positive,
that's incredible,
what the interaction
and the intersection is.
And so I'm just watching it
and it's super-interesting
to me, and I think the
biggest thing that I wanna
get out of this talk is to
encourage you to take chances.
Too many of you're playing it safe.
Too many of you're worried
about what other people think,
and what people are gonna think,
and what your crew's gonna think.
And you've got ideas, like I sit here
and I look at all of you,
and I can just see the ideas.
You got thoughts, you got ideas,
you have intuition of what would work.
If you're askin' me why me,
or other people have won,
it's we didn't give a fuck
what you thought about our
thoughts, we just did it, and
we fuckin' let it play out.
That's it, that is facts, man.
The people that break
through are the ones who
just had a little more courage.
They either had what I had, which is a mom
that fuckin' put so much self esteem in me
that I just can't even think
I'm not the best in the world,
you know, I can't, she just did it.
Others came up a different
way, had different reasons.
Maybe you're numb, maybe you
fuckin' went the other way,
got beat up so much you
just fuckin' hit the bottom
and you're like fuck it, got
nothin' else to lose, right?
The video I posted yesterday on Instagram,
and the one that got like,
man it's like 20 million reach
on Facebook, where I talk about
just fuckin' fail on purpose, right.
Like watchin' all of you
guys interact with that.
I kinda mean that, it's crazy for me that,
I remember, I'll tell you a
story I've never told publicly.
I went to the White House,
Barack Obama invited seven people
to talk about tech and communication
and what the fuck was goin' on.
And I remember I sat down,
I'm in the oval office
with Barack fuckin' Obama, right.
And the CMO of Amex, and Angela,
who's now the CMO of Apple,
and these gangster marketing people.
And I remember sitting
there, and I walked in,
and I sat down, and I'm sittin' direct,
like I'm sittin' directly from Barack.
Oh by the way that was the
best part, I called him Barack
and everybody corrected me,
they're like, Mr. President.
I was like oh sorry, sorry,
thought somebody was gonna shoot me.
And actually in the slip, of
the way I called him Barack,
that was the only thing I
thought about on the Acela,
on the train back to
New York the whole time,
which is, fuck it, I've
been to the tippy top
of a human being, this is the
man that runs shit, period,
the free world, I felt better.
And so, that's what I want for everybody,
just that feeling where
no matter where you are,
you just don't care, you really don't.
And I know that's hard.
And honestly, if you ask me what I'm doin'
with my content right now,
I'm trying to be your shield,
I'm trying to make you
jump, and if you fail,
you just point to me and
be like, Gary told me.
Like he's the reason I fucked up,
he tricked me, he's a
piece of shit, I'm sorry.
Like I don't care what you do,
'cause I know if you'll jump
it's gonna feel a lot better.
'Cause it's regret.
The reason I keep tellin' you
guys to go to a nursing home
is I want you to get face
to face with somebody
who's not your grandparent,
that has regret comin' through their face.
And that's what's happening
in old person homes.
They have regret, telling you
right now, they have regret.
Even if you, like I feel
already like I can go now
and I did good, but I'll
still have tons of regret.
I'm like what if, and this
and fuck I shoulda bought,
I could've bought the
Jets if I stayed alive.
You know like, just random shit.
I'm tryin' to get people closer to regret,
because when regret scares
you, when you see regret,
like a horror movie, and
it shakes you to your core,
you bounce back the other
way and you start doin' shit
because you realize how ridiculous it is
that you're not doing stuff
'cause your homie might think it's stupid.
Or 'cause your older brother
had better grades than you.
Or 'cause your mom told you you
were never gonna be anybody.
And so, that's where I'm at,
that's where my head space is at.
I'm tryin' to hack attention,
I'm tryin' to understand
and synthesis culture.
But most of all, it doesn't matter
if you're wearin' a Supreme backpack,
or some Yeezy sneakers or this and that.
The thing that's true is like
six, seven things in life.
All this other stuff is disguising.
All this other stuff is
fulfilling insecurities.
you expressing yourself
to the world of who you are.
Most of you are wearing
everything you wear right now
as a quick, quick interaction
with everybody else
to try to tell everybody who you are.
The way you wear your hair,
man's wearin' a cap hoodie,
right, he's tryin' to say somethin'.
That's what we're doin'.
And the hair that you've got, you know,
beautiful by the way.
And so we're trying to say
somethin' about who we are,
real quick, and that's why I
love and fuck with fashion.
Not like, I don't love fashion,
but I love what it does for us.
It helps those of you
who don't communicate
like I do, communicate.
I just wanna make sure you're
usin' it to communicate,
not close some insecurities that you have
and you wanna fit in.
And that's what I love so much
about what's happening now,
is it feels like blank canvas.
Feels like, you know
what's crazy right now,
is if you've got any kind of audience
and you got just a
little bit of confidence,
you could do anything.
If you take the hundred people
that have the most confidence downstairs,
if they walk here with
an umbrella as a hat,
in the first 10 minutes,
everybody'd be like,
what the fuck, and an hour
later people are like,
yeah where do I get that umbrella?
And I'm fascinated by that.
And I implore you to
get into that mindset.
And so, I feel like anybody's
who's sitting here right now
is fuckin' with me, and I hope
you understand why you are.
Because, this is a great era,
especially for the subculture
that's sitting here,
there's a lot of minorities,
brown and black and girls
and I mean minorities
of not white male, which I am one of.
This is the greatest era,
'cause the internet's
the middleman and nobody stop,
why the fuck do you think Harvey Weinstein
and Kevin Spacey are gettin' taken down?
By the way, if you're a bad
person, and you're 60 years old,
you're shittin' your pants right now.
'Cause you're fuckin' next.
And do you know how happy I am about this?
Do you know how happy I am?
Do you know how happy I am
that the girl sittin' third row
in the middle, Kate Franklin,
somebody who worked for me
for a short period of time,
that I know every
interaction I had with her,
I know what she says behind my back,
I know why we're gonna meet
in an hour and talk again.
Doing the right thing is
always the right thing,
and this is finally the era
where that's gonna play out.
Because 20, 50 people used
to be able to hide shit.
And so it's about to get
much better or much worse,
depending on how you
decide to live your life.
And so, if you go read my first two books,
Crush It, and Thank You
Economy, very subtly
and very specifically I'm telling people
the shadows of our society
are about to change.
That I changed when I
learned social media,
when I, in my head, when I was like, fuck,
everybody's gonna know
everything about everything.
And so, since 2008, I've
just been livin' a different
kind of life, got you
know, and I just like it.
I think the only way to
survive and really win
is gonna be on good and
positivity and that's crazy.
That's super exciting.
And so I implore you to know one thing,
you know, I laugh when people
like, some of you I just met
and some of you I met on, you know,
I laugh when I leave a situation,
quick selfie, quick hello, quick love.
And I walk, and I know what's happening,
nine out of 10 times they're like,
oh man thank god he's as nice in person,
I was hoping he wouldn't suck.
It's always good, and I laugh because
I find it funny that
we've become so cynical
because of the world we've lived in
for the last hundred years,
that being nice or doing the right thing
is the positive outcome,
right, that it's not the expected.
That we're protecting ourselves
'cause we don't wanna be let down.
That even there's a saying,
like you don't wanna meet your hero.
It's like, it's so sad, and I don't think
that's gonna play out
the next hundred years
and so, most of you are very
young in your game, right?
You're thinking and your
aspiring in your brain
the way I did when I was in this audience
of where you're gonna be,
but it's still five, seven,
15, 20 years away, right?
I just wanna make sure that you realize
the quickest way, 'cause
everybody wants to get here quick,
it's always patience.
The quickest way to guarantee you'll get
to wherever you wanna get to,
is by treating every single
person you interact with
with serious love.
'Cause they will build
you, they will build you,
they will put you on your back.
And they're also the people
that will fucking tear you down
behind, you think somebody
who's in power, in charge,
who's got some juice, is
the one that you need to be
pandering too, those people
aren't doing' anything for you.
It's the people that you're
sitting next to right now.
Kindness is gonna be the currency
and that is where we're goin'
and it's fuckin' beautiful.
Like, it's real good.
Everybody thinks shit's bad now.
Let me just tell all of you
what's happening in culture
where we're spreading apart
and we're in an almost
intellectual civil war and
everything that's going on.
Let me tell you what's going on.
And remember that I said it.
This is just one step
backwards, two steps forward.
We needed to get exposed
because we were hiding
under the makeup of the
old media landscape.
We needed to just come to grips
that we still got some
shit to get through.
And now that it is on, like
we're in it, the lights are on
our differences, the lights
are on our shortcomings,
I'm happy, 'cause the way you go forward
is acknowledging and respecting
what the fuck is fucked up.
And so, I'm very optimistic.
I think the next five to
ten years are gonna suck,
the way it feels like it's sucking now.
I still don't think it's really sucking,
'cause you're in control,
you can dwell on what
you can't control, or you
can focus on what you can.
And so, I'm real excited,
I'm real excited.
I'm really grateful that
you guys are spendin'
45 minutes of your time, with everything
that's goin' on downstairs,
here with me so, thank you
and I appreciate you.
(audience applauding)
So look, I went super
heady and like up here
and emotional and like, up here.
But, while we've got this 25 minutes,
this is the time to get selfish as fuck
and let's go real down here, like a.k.a,
yo, how do I sell hats on LinkedIn?
(audience laughing)
All right, my man.
- [Man With Backwards Cap]
Gary, first of all thank you.
I'm an up and coming rapper
so I might freestyle,
'cause fuck it, you said
you're all on the Gary V show.
My name's Zach, I turned
20 on the 20th of November,
I'm a Scorpio, here's the deal, you say
drop a song every day for 365 days but,
I'm like wait, there's no
way that can have quality.
'Cause it's quality over
quantity, but honestly
I'm astonishing the reality that way.
Let me slow down a bit,
'cause my heart is beating--
(Gary laughing)
Honestly I might crash, but it's okay
'cause you say fuck it,
fail on purpose, I'm back.
'Cause I got a purpose.
A lot these people, no one's worthless,
and no one's worth less than anyone else.
Not trying to inspire, but let me inquire
the knowledge from you real quick.
This is off the top.
Anyway back to the top pick,
I hope I'm in your top picks
when you think about your vlog shit.
I hope my song on that,
it's D-Co on SoundCloud,
you should search that, hit this,
anyway, here's the question.
- Ah-ha, good job, man. (clapping)
(audience applauding)
- [Man With Backwards Cap] You
say upload a song 365 days--
- And I think I clarified it
in one of the last sessions,
where I was like, look, oh
actually we haven't put it out.
It was the one with Big Cred, right?
It's, if you've got it like
that, put it out like that.
My big thing is that
Michael Jackson and Prince,
sat on hundreds of songs we haven't heard.
And so, to your point, quality, quantity,
look what I'm going,
I'm putting out fucking
a ton of shit every day.
And, I have a good feeling,
'cause I'm lookin' at it every
day that it's quality, right?
And so, if you can put
out 113 songs, do that.
And if you can put out 365, do that.
Because these are at bats.
Music's interesting, music's like content.
You're literally one song away.
My man, you're literally,
like I need you to
really wrap your fuckin'
head around what I'm about to tell you.
15 years ago, you had to get
found, you had to get signed,
you had to get through the,
you know when I talk about
this, a lot artists came in,
I made a reference to
like, you had to get found
by L.A. Reed and then
put on, and some girl
jumped in the comments
on Insta, she's like,
and even that doesn't happen.
She's like I was signed
by L.A. fuckin' Reed
and I got caught up in the system
and my shit never even came out.
So 20 years ago man, you
had no fuckin' chance.
It was fuckin' .000, it was ridiculous.
Now you, you, can put
something on SoundCloud
or Spotify tomorrow, and
it just might be the song.
So yeah, I want you to put
out as much as you've got.
And if you only got six good songs in you,
then you're not gonna have
a career anyway, right?
And so, or, maybe I'm
wrong, you know actually
as I said it, I'm takin' a step back.
One great song is a lot
of people's entire career.
Right, right, so (laughing)
let's not call people out.
And so, yeah man, I just want
you putting out stuff, right.
When I was in Mount Ida
College, battle rap was real hot
and people used to really
go up against each other.
And some of the shit that I heard
is like the coolest best shit I ever heard
and a week later I'd talk to 'em
and they don't even
remember what they said
'cause they weren't writing
and then battling bullshit
they were like really
doin' it from the top.
That's why I have DRock
man, some of the best,
you know that fuckin'
video with that little kid
in the liquor store, where I
told him not to worry about
YouTube views, that got so many views?
That would've been lost in
fuckin' space back in the day,
back in my day two years ago,
that woulda been lost in space
but now that I have them filming, right?
So yeah man I think, I
think the quality quantity
conversation was for a day and age
where distribution was different.
It's true, but as many
at bats as you can get
because what is crazy is one song.
And sometimes it comes early.
Lil Yatchy just, it happened fast, right.
His one song happened quick.
You know, Kylie fuckin' Sa, you know or
one person puts it on, you know?
- [Man In Backwards Cap] Thank you.
- You got it.
My man.
- Hey Gary, Harry Duran,
host of Podcast Junkies.
I have two pieces of
gratitude and a question.
The first is, I don't
know if you remember,
oh first, thank you for
gettin' me in here for free--
- [Gary] No worries.
- 'Cause this is on you and
your text message, that worked.
- [Gary] Go figure.
- I don't know if you remember
C.J. Boling from VidSummit--
- [Gary] Of course.
- I just wanted to give
you a quick update.
He was at 30 followers on
YouTube, he's at 10,000 now.
And I just saw it yesterday, so kudos
to that again.
- That's incredible.
- The question is, I'm
more interested rather than
a tip or a tactic, to
understand what you OS is like,
so what's something you've
changed your mind about recently?
- That's a great question.
What have I, god, you know it's funny
'cause I'm narrow and deep,
changed by mind, changed my mind
I don't have a quick
answer, but I'll tell you
the best thing that I've
changed my mind about,
which I guess I changed my mind
but it was more my actions.
I've become much better at radical candor
at VaynerMedia, I'm so positive,
and I love honey over
vinegar, that I think at times
the second time there
was conflict or issue,
where I decided to deploy more optimism,
and more honey and more
sunshine, and hoped
when they went back out of
my office into the company,
or my audience, I think that
I'm starting to do a better job
of speeding up the process where I'm like,
look, you're fucking up
and you're gonna get fired
and let me tell you what to do.
Instead of making that
the fourth conversation,
it's now starting to be closer
to the 2.5 conversation.
And I've gotta be honest with you,
I've felt the very positive
ramifications of that
and it's taken me from positive and good
and a little closer to
shooting it straight.
You know, I talk about my
dad, that was more about
my actions and not stealing
and not doing the wrong thing
and not bullshitting, but
I think I'm going through
a weird version, because
Vayner's getting big
and I have almost a
thousand employees now,
and I've seen some of the things
I don't like about Vayner,
face to face, and it's on me.
The think I've changed my mind about is,
when I think about the honey
empire, and honey over vinegar
I used to say, honey over vinegar,
but I think in my actions
I was honey, honey, honey,
honey, honey over vinegar, or even worse,
the thing I'm most fearful
of, honey, honey, honey,
honey, honey, you're fired.
And if you were the kind
of person that wasn't
self-aware, if you didn't hear the vinegar
even though I was trying to tell you
in every piece of honey,
like, you're fucking up,
shit's not right, it still felt like
I fuckin' pulled the rug
out from underneath you.
So I would say the
adoptance of radical candor
in the mix of my tool belt,
in my Swiss army knife,
is taking me to the next level.
- [Harry] And I imagine they
appreciate you more in the end
'cause you were honest with them.
- You know, it's funny, a certain group,
that 25% that was my
vulnerability, no question
is probably gonna appreciate it more.
And at least, if nothing
else, they're not stunned.
Even though for me it was like,
how did you not see it in the nuances.
Now it's just more black and white.
So adopting a little more black and white.
- [Harry] Thank you.
- You got it.
- Gary, what's up man,
Ivan, good to see you again.
- [Gary] Great to see you, Ivan.
- So, my wife and I just started
running a YouTube channel,
it's probably not for
the demographic here,
it's ballet videos for young children,
so it appeals to parents
and stuff like that.
- [Gary] Don't sleep on people's ballet
obsessions up in here.
- So, we produce video,
they're expensive to make
but that's not an issue,
we're giving content,
giving content--
- [Gary] Why are they expensive to make?
- Just costing to rent out
studio, editors, green screen,
makin' it look professional,
all that stuff.
- One thing I'm gonna press
on is just give thought,
if you're going too professional
given the reality of where you're at.
- So, the money thing isn't an issue,
you know, it's fine--
- Okay, respect.
- So we're givin' out
content all the time,
we're not sure, we've thought about
either reaching out to brands
and getting sponsorships,
you know, tactic like the Backpack Kid.
We thought about hey, do we create our own
ballet shoe and sell merchandise?
What if we're not sure, we're giving,
we're not sure what the ask
is, or if there even is an ask?
- I mean I think you're in the
best fuckin' spot ever then.
To me, I never thought,
I'm a business man,
I'm and entrepreneur, so I
never thought a K-Swiss sneaker
was gonna be the ask.
To me, it came, things come to me.
So, I think that if you're in a place
where you're not sure, then
I wouldn't stress yourself
of coming up with one,
'cause if you force it,
it's gonna fail.
It's not gonna come natural from you,
they're gonna feel it's not natural,
and it's just gonna break.
I would just tell you to
keep building leverage
and attention, because
when you wanna deploy it,
I mean this whole thing,
like yeah, I've got a sneaker
and I've got a book, but
these are inexpensive things
along the way, in return
for what I'm giving.
I don't wanna ask at all,
so that I can ask for my final ask,
which is, if the Jets go up for sale
and I come up a couple dollars short,
I think I'm gonna
crowdfund it from the world
and close the gap, right, and so,
I don't think you have to
force yourself into an ask.
And, I think you need
to stay curious and open
to see if it comes to
you, but I don't think
you have to force it if you can afford to.
And if you get to a place
where you can't afford to,
give yourself six good months,
and that might be right now,
if you feel like, okay, in
six months we're gonna be
forced to doing something, and
start being real thoughtful
but it's much better if
it comes naturally to you.
- Cool, I like the six month
thing and that's very practical
and yeah, like you said,
we don't wanna do a,
we can easily do like a
one ninety-nine per month
subscription, but I feel
like those are just so,
everyone's doin' it and
we don't wanna just be
those type of people.
- Let me tell you something
right now, and for all of you.
You will never succeed
if you sell something
you don't believe in.
So many of you are selling something
because it seems like
it's the thing that sells.
And you will lose.
100%, to stand by your product,
you got to love it first.
So I get that hoodies, right,
and beanies, and sneakers,
and backpacks feel right now,
but if you love your shit,
it will come to you in three years.
Nobody was wearin' socks
that had cool shit on it
five years ago, right.
So if you really believe
in it and you love it,
it will come to you.
And things go up and down,
things go up and down.
Yeah, don't force it.
- Thank you.
- But, if you know
you need it in six months,
and I saw how you reacted,
start gettin' curious
and start really gettin'
deep in ballet culture,
and maybe in the depths
of ballet culture, on some small hashtag,
you see somebody doin' somethin' fly,
and you're like okay, that's gonna emerge.
Maybe you DM them, you
wanna do it together,
or maybe you're inspired by it
and DJ your own version of it, cool.
- [Ivan] Can I get a
right hook real quick?
- Um-hm.
- For those with young children out there,
Buttercup Ballet on YouTube.
- [Gary] Good for you.
- Thanks, Gary.
- [Gary] You got it.
- [Man] Hey guys, just real
quick, I have to be this guy
but we have time for five more questions
if we make 'em quick, please.
- You got it, and if you're in line,
I'll try to make six
if I go real quick, go.
- I'll be quick, yo what's up.
G, bless up, you're an amazing person.
- Thank you.
- I met you back at
Shoe Palace, that was
an amazing day because
when I looked at the
vlog after you posted it
I was like skimmin'
through, skimmin' through,
about like 18 minutes of
that shit was just like,
not Shoe Palace, and then
it gets to Shoe Palace
and, I was the guy that
you put the clip in,
it was the only clip.
- I love it.
- And it's so funny, 'cause
I was at an event of Friday
supporting a friend and
some random person was like,
yo, Gary V posted a video with you,
and I thought that was
like the craziest thing.
I don't have a specific
question to ask you
because you give out so much free content.
I just take it and I apply it and I do
trial and error in everything.
What I do have to ask you though is,
I wanna challenge you
to rock, paper, scissors
and if I beat you, we have a sit down.
- Okay so, I've only
done this one other time
and it was with Jerome Jarre
and he won 'cause he cheated.
Are you good at cheating too?
- I'm good at winning.
- Tell the truth.
- [Man Asking Question]
I'm good at winning.
- But are you good at it
because you kind of like
actually like practice
rock, paper, scissors
and you know what's gonna happen?
- My girl and I always
play rock, paper, scissors
for who pays, and normally--
- [Gary] You make your girl pay for shit?
- No, wait, wait, no--
- What the fuck?
- Hey, whoa, whoa, whoa,
wait, wait, nah, nah--
- I'm kidding.
- She a hustler.
- Respect.
She's independent, she don't need--
- Respect, I get it, whatever she wants.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] All right, yeah, let's do it.
- Cool.
- All right, what does it
go, one, two, three, shoot?
- Yeah, two out of three.
- No, no, one.
- Straight up?
- Yeah.
(muffled)
This dude came here, he
was like, I'm gonna take
a lot of time, now we're doin' this shit,
then he wants--
(audience laughing)
then he wants, right, right my man, right?
Then he want two out of fuckin' three.
Why not a seven game series?
One time, ready?
Is it, well I wanna make sure, so one--
- Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
- Rock, papers, scissors,
then shoot, got it.
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
You got it.
(audience applauding)
- Who do I need to talk to?
- Gary at VaynerMedia.
- Well I've been tryin' that, I need a--
- You're gonna say I beat
you in rock, paper, scissors.
(audience laughing)
And I'm gonna fuckin'
have a meeting with you.
Let's go.
- What's up Zeus, my name's
Zeus, from Shadow Group.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you.
- I just started a
YouTube, zero subscribers--
- [Gary] Good.
- Real proud of that, that I just started.
- [Gary] I'm proud of you too, man.
- Yeah, and I honestly wanted to get,
I'm trying to build up
my Instagram as well
and I would like to get an
audit, an Instagram audit
from you, and maybe just you
DM me and see what you think
I can do, or what you think I should do.
- [Gary] Okay, Andy's gonna do it for you,
'cause he's smarter than me.
- All right.
- [Gary] Done.
- I kinda wanna play him
paper, rock, scissors,
just to take his spot.
- Well you can see if he gives up his spot
but I'm gonna move Zeus, appreciate it.
- Hey Gary.
- How are you?
- My name's Omar, we actually met
in Washington Square
Park back in New York.
- [Gary] Yes, that was a fun night, man.
- It was, it was.
- Yeah, I remember you
actually, what's up man?
- Oh thank you, so my question
is, you always talk about
how difficult client services is,
so I just wanna know, what was
that first conversation like
when you were getting that
first client for $40,000?
And also, I understand kind
of the long term vision
of VaynerMedia, so how
do you see it moving from
essentially the client
service marketing machine,
to becoming the private equity machine--
- So, I'll answer number two.
I'm building up my
management team, my winners,
so that one day, just on intuition,
I'll feel like it's ready
for me not to be there.
Then I'll spend another six months.
My intuition, my guess right
now is three years from now.
I'll spend another six months
tying up all the loose ends,
and then in that same six months
I'll start really lookin' for brands.
You know Barney did such a mizpah for me,
you know I'm so excited,
'cause I want K- Swi,
I mean I'm focused on this, right.
The plans we have for next year,
the way I'm thinkin' about
the threes and fours,
I really want K-Swiss to completely,
I mean, for the people that
are really understanding,
I don't think people really
understand K-Swiss's spot
in hip hop culture back in the day like,
real shit, Ice-T, like really.
So I think, I'm excited
'cause I'm givin' it my all
and I want them to win way more than
what they compensate, but for me,
this is a nice little middle test case
for like rejuvenating brands,
'cause that's what I'm thinking about.
So that's how I'm thinking about it.
As far as the first
part, you just gotta ask.
Like, if you're asking for
yourself, like getting clients,
is that where you're goin'?
- [Omar] No, not
particularly, I was just--
- You're just curious?
- [Omar] Yes.
- I just asked.
I just, you know, people were emailing me
about Wine Library, I knew
VaynerMedia was coming,
I just would look at their
signature in their email
and be like, hey, I'm
starting a marketing company
the way I built this Wine Library,
do you wanna be my client?
- [Omar] Right, that's awesome.
- Yeah, I don't think people
understand the game of asking.
- [Omar] Right, and never
say no for the other person.
- Never say no for the
other person, my man.
- Right, last thing, just kinda somethin'
I mentioned before, I'm
a senior in college,
obviously, I was doing the
whole Wall Street thing,
intern at Goldman Sachs,
but I'm actively kind of
trying to segue into
VaynerMedia, so I just wanna say
hopefully maybe I'll see you
in the next few months or so.
- [Gary] I hope so man, pleasure.
- Hi, I'm too short, hi, Gary, oh my god,
I had to do the five second
rule to come up here.
Okay, first of all thank you,
I'm so grateful to be here
and thank you to my boyfriend
and inspirational artist,
Louii King, L-O-U-I-I King.
So the main reason I'm here well,
I'm in the health and fitness industry
and I've had my own business
and my nutrition center
running for four years, and I love it,
but I just find so much more passion
in singing and writing--
- [Gary] Good for you.
- Yeah, the crazy thing is,
I'm like trying to balance
everything and I wake up at five a.m.,
I got to sleep at 11, 12, one a.m.
So I'm trying to balance everything out.
Social media's working out,
I just started up my YouTube
but I'm having a hard
time staying consistent
with building content.
So I was just wondering, should I just
document the struggle?
- Yes, yes.
- [Woman Asking Question]
Document how busy I am.
- This is why, you already know,
that's why you used the word document,
you know that was the
biggest breakthrough for me
for my audience in the last three years,
the documenting versus creating.
If you just, guys, we're
interested in each other.
I'm interested in your struggle.
I'm interested in what your
favorite fast food place is.
I'm interested in, are you a Laker fan.
People are just interested in shit.
- Yeah, and the crazy thing is,
I'm also really involved in
the whole motivational thing
because of my past of drug
abuse and gang violence
and what not, and being
an entrepreneur now,
so it's like--
- Can I tell you what's holding you up?
- [Woman Asking Question] Yeah.
- And all of you.
You hear me, you just don't wanna accept
the fuckin' patience part.
- [Woman Asking Question]
I'll agree with that.
- You're young, you are young.
You make, you make, like people that are,
Barney, how old are you?
- [Barney] 45.
- Barney's 45 and he's young as fuck.
Right, like he just is,
he's got 30 fuckin'
more years in the game.
Do know how long 30 years is?
What's fucking you up right now,
is what's fucking them all up.
You hear me, you're like,
yo, Gary V, patience yeah,
but you don't live it.
You don't live it like I do.
I lived it, and I'm still livin' it.
Do you know where I'm gonna end up?
(snapping) The tippy fuckin' top.
You know where I am now, upper middle.
So I'm patient, I'm grinding, I'm here,
I'm hustling down there,
I'm fuckin' hustling,
patient for whatever my like,
you know, final stop is gonna be.
You're just not patient.
Like if you're feelin' any angst,
it's 'cause you don't love the process
more than the results.
You're thinkin' about
$10,000 a month in Adsense
instead of loving the fuckin' dirt,
and loving this grind moment.
And the second you fall
in love with the grind,
for real, 19 years of it, not a month.
When you fuckin' really
fall in love with the grind
and sit here, how old are you, my man?
How old are you, I know
that's inappropriate.
- [Woman Asking Question] 27.
- 19 years, if you're
like cool, at fuckin' 46
it's gonna get goin'.
If you A, knew who young,
Barney, how young do you feel?
- [Barney] Well yeah,
young in this industry,
it keeps you young.
- Young, if you knew what 46 felt like,
19 years wouldn't scare you.
Right now it does.
'Cause it's almost your
whole fuckin' life.
That's it, patience.
- [Woman Asking Question] Got it.
- Don't do every, if you're
really grinding five to 11,
well then you're fuckin' doin' the work,
now the next part is
patience, and then your talent
is gonna take you where
it's gonna take you.
Either you got it or you don't.
- [Woman Asking Question] I do.
- And if you do, you
have it to some level.
And somewhere between
Beyonce and Shmeonce,
is where you're gonna end up.
And you just, as long as
you're putting in the grind
and having the hustle,
you just gotta respect
that somewhere between
Beyonce and Shmeonce, right?
Or, you're pickin' the wrong thing
and you're romantic
about music, but you're
the best architect that ever
lived, but you never tried it.
That's the framework.
If you're workin' as hard as
you can, and you're patient,
then your talent is gonna take
you to where it is, right?
Or, did you pick the wrong thing.
Listen, I wish I could be a rapper.
But I just know, I'm
not, and I know I've got
rapper tendencies, in the way that I talk,
but I'm an entrepreneur.
I will fuckin' build a bigger business
than all of you combined
every day of the week.
That's the fuckin' facts.
That's it, take it for what it is,
and if that motivates you, show me,
email me in 15 years
with this clip, show me.
- [Woman Asking Question]
Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
- [Man] This is our last question, guys.
- My man.
- Hey, how's it goin' man,
my name's Austin Reynolds
from South Florida, off the
rip, I just wanted to tell you
thank you so much for inspiring all of us.
I've gone through some
difficulties in the past couple
years and your words have
really got me through
some struggles and everything and--
- Means a lot to me, man.
- My question for you is,
I've gone through probably 15 surgeries,
physical therapies, here
and there and I'm trying to
piece all the documentation together
and try to make an impact to others
by sharing them my positivity
that nothing's ever really hold me back
or held me down, and I
was gonna see what someone
from your stature, from
someone who's made it
in the industry to someone
who's trying to become
and up and coming, how do you get there?
- How you get to the next spot?
- [Austin] Yes.
- You know it's gonna be the
repeat of the last thing,
and the truth is, you
know, your circumstance
matters so fuckin' much,
because it's one thing
if you've got less adversity in your life,
regardless of what it is, for
everybody else in this room
who's not in a machine right now, right?
If you're in the negative mindset.
It's a whole different
thing to the audience
that sees themselves in you.
It's real easy to get dark.
It's real easy to not see it, right?
So it's gonna be patience and
things of that nature, right.
It's gonna be the same
stuff, and it's gonna be
the stuff that I started with, which is,
so, back to what you were saying,
'cause I wanna take my
last two minutes with you.
- [Austin] Okay.
- How are you putting out your content?
- Through Instagram and through Snapchat.
I haven't really executed
anything, I've kind of,
have a very large base back
at home in South Florida
and everyone kind of knows
who I am in my home city
and high school, and my
college that I went to.
So everyone's kind of known who I am,
and I've always kind of been uplifted,
I've never been held back,
never looked at anything.
I traveled 3,000 miles just in California
to see you with my buddy
so, everything kinda
doesn't hold me back, so what,
I just am having struggles
kinda getting the content--
- What do you want to happen?
No bullshit, like you
wanna, like from a fame
and financial standpoint.
- I don't want any financial,
I don't want any fame,
I want people to read
that I'm four foot four,
22 years old, went through 15 surgeries,
and born with dwarfism,
that I'm at ComplexCon
in Santa Monica, and
I didn't let anything,
any shit hold me back.
(audience applauding)
- Well good news, hopefully
DRock's been filming,
somebody's been filming.
We'll definitely make sure that happens
to some small degree.
Let me give you a good piece of advice.
You need to get somebody
who does what DRock
and Babin do, and you
need to start vlogging,
and somebody filming you.
And I'll help you get somebody
for free for a year, got it?
- [Austin] Got it.
- And by the way, not beca,
by the way, real quick,
not 'cause I'm gonna pay,
I'm not that great of a guy,
I mean it, it's because there's so many
amazing creators who'd want to do it,
and they're gonna know that I care,
and if they do it for him for a year
then I will do something,
I don't know what,
that's number one.
Number two, you're gonna make
it a Facebook Watch show.
So everybody's tryin'
to blast off on YouTube
and it's hard, 'cause supply
and demand of attention,
there's a lot of shit on YouTube,
and there's not a lot
of growth hacking ways
to get there, collaborations,
there's some stuff,
thumbnails, titles, but
it's a fucking grind
even for us, we haven't popped it.
Facebook Watch, for all of you right now,
I'm telling you right now, I'm so happy,
I haven't said this really publicly yet,
Facebook Watch is a huge
opportunity, here's why.
Facebook wants to kill YouTube,
'cause Zucks is a gangster.
(audience laughing)
I know he doesn't look like it,
but take every gangster
downstairs combined
and they don't have shit
on one little Zucks.
Dude is a fuckin' gangster.
So, here's what Facebook's doing.
If you make a Watch show,
and if you don't know
what I mean when I say
Facebook Watch, news alert,
Google, what is Facebook Watch?
Read it, understand it, start your vlog
on Facebook Watch, not on YouTube.
Because Facebook wants
Facebook Watch to work, right.
So they're gonna give
you extra distribution
even though you got nobody.
Take your Facebook fan
page, take your Insta,
take your Snap, take your YouTube,
take the signature in your email,
and push everything into
your Facebook Watch.
Call 36 of your homies and be like, yo,
it would just mean the fuckin' world to me
if you subscribed to my Facebook Watch,
and the first one that comes
out, just share it and like it.
Got it?
Just fuckin', I always talk a, this is why
I love this culture, it's just mix tapes
from the back of your
fuckin' hoop-di, you know.
It's just the baseball card show, like,
I got goosebumps all up in my body
when I walked down there.
I'm like, this is a
baseball card show, right?
It was how I grew, it
was sellin' blow pops
out of my backpack, that's all
this is, it's the same shit.
It's just with attention,
and the stakes are bigger.
Facebook Watch vlog, get
everybody in your high school
and college and anybody that
ever gave a fuck about you.
Take two straight days and just
fuckin' lounge and be like,
this link, follow me on this show.
When I have a new book comin' out,
like I have Crushing
It come out in January,
during my holiday vacation this winter,
I will lay there and hit
up every person one-by-one,
not bulk blast email.
Not an Instagram story.
One, by one, by one, and
be like, yo, buy my book.
And so, everybody here can do that
for whatever the fuck they want.
Get 813 people to follow your Watch show,
get all of them on the first episode,
you gotta text 'em back again.
Real grinding, 15 hours
a day, bus dev'ing,
sliding into the DMs,
hitting up everybody, right?
You get a thousand
people to like and share
your first episode of a
Facebook Watch vlog, right,
and share it, somethin' will happen.
Mark my words.
- [Austin] Thank you so much.
- You're welcome so much.
(audience applauding)
1:30 to 3:30, I will be
at the K-Swiss booth.
Come through, buy a pair, or not,
take a picture, or not.
Hug it out, or not, but
I appreciate all of you,
have a good day.
(audience applauding)
Love it, hope you enjoyed that.
Would love to get your three cents, not,
three cents in the comment
section on two things,
one, what was the best beverage
you had during Thanksgiving?
And two, what was the unique, new insight
from this keynote that
caught your attention?
See ya.
(uplifting music)